tulsi gabbard is a former congresswoman
and presidential candidate joins us now
to react
congresswoman this is your party i
understand it but does this help
americans to
put the irs on steroids and double their
personnel
it doesn't it doesn't you know you you
look at those numbers that you broke out
and the messaging that's coming out of
the democrats in congress saying hey
this will only apply to the wealthy
we're only taxing the wealthy well
that's only one to two percent of all
taxpayers so why in the world do they
need 80 billion dollars and 87 000 new
hires in order to go after one to two
percent of taxpayers their math
absolutely does not add up which should
be frightening and concerning because
this means exactly what you said they're
coming after us they're coming after
entrepreneurs they're coming after small
business owners they're coming after our
middle class hard-working americans
there's no question about that and then
you layer on top of that what you just
mentioned
their their criminal division with the
power of enforcement
of a gun essentially and how we have
already seen it's not a hype it's not a
theory that the irs has also like many
of these other federal agencies abuse
their power to go after political
opponents we have seen them do this
with lois lerner under the obama
administration there were no
consequences there and she was directly
targeting directly targeting blatantly
conservative
organizations and so this dangerous
trend that we are seeing that happened
gradually over years but everything from
the irs to department of homeland
security their counterterrorism division
the fbi the department of justice we are
seeing how they are more blatantly in
broad daylight being weaponized to
target political opponents of those in
power and anyone who dares to dissent or
question or challenge their actions and
policies do you realize that their
system is so antiquated that i think
they were using cobalt and they can't
keep up with the amount of calls i did
to get 1200 calls per second around the
country with people who are confused
about our complex tax system which keeps
changing do you know that out of all the
money that's earmarked for the irs only
five of the 87 billion is for increa is
improving the technology how dumb is
that
uh it's it's worse than dumb this is
government bureaucracy at its worst
rather than actually identifying the
problem saying hey how do we more
efficiently serve the needs of the
american people and and increase our
ability to deliver and serve them they
are taking our money this is money that
is coming out of our pockets and our
paychecks to go and plus up their force
and their ability to go and take more
money from us rather than actually
fixing the inefficiencies in their
antiquated systems 51 of the audits last
year went after taxpayers who made less
than seventy five thousand dollars so
unless they're gonna change their
doctrine all of a sudden i'm pretty sure
that the average american is going to
feel the uh the scrutiny of the irs in a
way that we're not prepared for nor do
we have the high price accounting firms
to fight for us for in many cases unless
someone turbo tax is going to help us
out uh thanks so much congresswoman
always great to see you tulsi
thanks brian and guess what uh don't
make plans for friday night you're going
to be hosting tucker uh so 8 o'clock
eastern time that's what i hear yes no
you can't get out of it you're going to
be here chelsea thanks so much for
joining us i look forward to seeing you
thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight